keilly dinner reacts to receiving the
lowest rating possible from the Better
Business Bureau the Lib kick creator
took to her app on Wednesday to speak
out after Kylie cosmetics grade went
from an F to C for its poor delivery
services we've been working really
really hard these past few months to
make as many little kids as we possibly
can the BBB adjusted the company's grade
to no rating after claiming it wasn't
aware of the true volume of the reality
stars business and Kylie had a few words
for her loyal customers my new children
because so many of you spoke out I'm
excited to tell you that the Better
Business Bureau has looked at the facts
and changed the rating the 18 year old
even spoke out against her haters I'm
sick and tired of people coming for my
business I love everything about Kylie
cosmetics and I will do anything in my
power to protect and improve it every
day and make you guys happy I don't want
to respond to the haters but you guys
deserve an answer and to know the facts